today on the matt welsh show a few
months ago the entire corporate media
condemned a woman as a bigot in a
transphobe when she complained about a
man exposing himself inside the women's
locker room at wii spa in los angeles
but in recent weeks the media has
stopped talking about this case
completely and that's because of the
recent revelations about this man and
what he was really doing inside that
locker room they don't want us to talk
about the story anymore because of that
but we will today also the mayor of san
francisco defends herself against
charges of hypocrisy after being seen
partying masculists at a nightclub and
daycare workers are caught on tape
trying to force a mask onto a very
very young child and the former head of
the fda says that the whole uh six feet
of social distancing rule was arbitrary
and nobody knows where it came from and
also the bite administration now wants
permanent access to all of your banking
information and your transact
transaction history who could possibly
object to that we'll talk about that
today and much more on the matt walsh
show
let's begin today with a trip down
memory lane i want to take you back to
ancient history to a time
that our forefathers told us about all
the way back to june 24th 2021 in those
days of yore something happened which
the media certainly hopes to leave
buried under the sand out of sight and
out of mind and out of memory it was the
incident at the wii spa in los angeles
as you may still recall if you're as old
as me and you can think back to all the
way back to three months ago the wii spa
was the site of controversy when a woman
who goes by cubana angel on instagram
uploaded a video of herself confronting
the spa staff over a naked man who
exposed himself inside the women's
locker room she said that she was in the
locker room along with a bunch of other
women and young girls when the man
entered and revealed himself in all of
his maleness to the females in the room
to refresh our memories let's watch a
little bit of the conversation between
cubana angel and the staff towards the
end of this clip you also you'll also
get to see the mustachioed white knight
gallop into the scene to stick up for
the naked exhibitionist man in the
locker room and condemn the woman for
her big her bigotry and her transphobia
let's watch that again
so you don't so it's okay i just want to
be clear with you it's okay
it's okay for a man to go into the
women's section
show his penis
around the other woman young little
girls under age your spa we spa could
done that is that what you're saying
like i asked
it's so he can stay there
he could stay there
what sexual orientation i see
it lets me know he's a man
he's a man
he is a man he is not no female
he is not a female
he is not a female
give her her money back are you talking
about the transgender person there's no
such thing as transgender he has a
okay
he has a penis he has penises hanging
out
okay no i'm not one actually i'm a woman
who knows how to stand up and speak up
for my right as a woman
i have a right to feel comfortable
without a man
exposing himself okay no you go
somewhere else
okay so that's right
no he's not a transgender he has a penis
just like you do
are you are you are you are you do i
understand no yeah okay it's not okay
it's not okay okay that's traumatizing
to see that i'm a woman i think this is
a place right here i'm told only for
women so how dare you sit up here and
tell me i don't have a right as a woman
i'm telling you he has a penis
a full and testicle okay
and my favorite thing about that video
has always been
when you hear the white knight in the
background and you don't see him yet and
he says are you talking about the
transgender person
and uh and then the camera pans over and
before you see him you have an image in
your head of what this guy is going to
look like and he looks exactly like him
it's like a premonition you know exactly
what he's going to look like and he
looks like that and then you got the
smarmy look on his face the entire time
while this woman is trying to explain
basic biology no no he has a penis and
testicles that's a that's a man that's a
man
and the white knight's standing there
like okay all right
this condescending look as if
as if he's the one talking to a crazy
person when it's the other way around so
the staff was against her the white
knight was against her a man had
stripped off his clothes in front of her
without her consent and most of the
people in the building were taking the
man's side
and this pattern would hold true on a
larger scale the left-wing social media
mob the entire mainstream media along
with the antifa terrorists who showed up
at the wii spa in the following days to
assault and intimidate the small group
of protesters who came to support kibana
angel and the other female victims in
the case all of these groups condemned
the women
as bigots and transphobes
even as hoaxers and scam artists
here's a quick sample of some of the
headlines related to this incident
from slate violence over an alleged
transphobic hoax shows the danger of
underestimating anti-trans hate
the independent lgbtq advocates suggest
alleged trans exposure incident
at the la spa was faked
pink news says bigot screaming at spa
staff for not being transphobic sparks
furious protests
the guardian a nightmare scenario how an
anti-trans instagram post led to
violence in the streets
in the new republic how tucker carlson
and a story about a possibly fictional
trans person fueled two weeks of violent
right-wing protests there was an article
in the advocate titled was trans nudity
incident at los angeles spa staged
and this
article actually suggests
that the whole thing may have been a
right-wing false flag operation this was
published on july 9th the piece reads a
trans activist and journalist writing
under the pseudonym robert lansing says
the whole thing may have been an
elaborate hoax
quote a source of the spa told the blade
there's no record of of any of its usual
transgender clients on its appointments
guest list on the day in question
lansing wrote an article published on
wednesday treatment at the spa is by
appointment only and most of its
transgender clients are well known to
the staff
also anonymous sources with the los
angeles police department told lansing
there's no corroborating evidence that a
trans person was at we spa that day no
obviously trans person can be seen in
the video and no other clients have
offered evidence either
a woman falsely accused of being the
trans woman who so offended cubana angel
has been harassed and received death
threats
it also remains a possibility that there
was a person unknown to the wii spa
staff who pretended to be transgender to
create an inciting incident lansing
continued in 2015 anti-transgender
activists in washington state
deliberately encouraged men to enter
women's women's facilities
one cisgender man entered a swimming
pool changing area wearing only board
shorts while claiming that he had a
right to be there
he was removed from the premises without
charges being filed
ah yes so it didn't happen
but if it did happen it was a right-wing
conspiracy
that's what they decided to go with
they also claimed that there's no
evidence that this trans person exists
even though multiple women can be heard
in the video reporting that they just
saw the guy's penis in the women's
locker room five seconds earlier
apparently multiple women testifying to
their experiences does not count as
evidence
that's no evidence
at least it doesn't count as evidence
when the person being accused is trans
if the person accused was a straight
white conservative male
a quote unquote cisgender male as they
say
all it would take is one woman
testifying to something that allegedly
occurred at any point within the last
half century and that would qualify not
just as evidence but as indisputable
proof
that's the way these things work as we
have seen
now the headlines just cited are some of
the more egregious examples but every
headline about this case in the
left-wing press
was along these lines they all agreed
that the women who complained about the
transgender person were hateful
transphobes that the whole thing was
probably some sort of hoax
that was the media spin until the last
few weeks
when they suddenly stopped talking about
the story altogether
and if you're wondering why they all
felt so eerily silent
why the left stopped condemning the
horrific transphobia of cubana angel and
her conspirators
it's because the full truth has come out
and the truth is
well the truth is exactly what you
should expect the quote-unquote trans
woman who entered the locker room that
day
is a sex offender with a long history of
allegations and convictions
his name is darren mirager he's 52 years
old he's now wanted by police on six
felony charges of indecent exposure
after five females at the wii spa that
day five of them including one minor
reported to police
that he exposed his erect penis to them
in the locker room
he now has two warrants for his arrest
stemming from this incident and has not
turned himself into into the police
the new york post has more information
about this sex predator who every
left-wing media outlet in the country
defended
it says quote
sources tell the post that mirager had
been banned by we spa back in 2019 due
to customer complaints of an erection in
the women's section
but mirager wasn't recognized by the
front desk in june because they were
wearing a mask
wii spa did not respond for comment
uh mirager says he was interviewed by
the post and he says i don't remember
being banned adding that there was one
complaint but maintains it was meritless
and based on transphobia mirager who
stands six foot two and weighs around
200 pounds says the women are mistaking
a large appendage for an erection
roger says i don't have a small penis
but you can't say that's an erection
what if you use the men's room and
someone said they don't like the size or
shape of your penis that's what they're
doing
but this isn't roger's first incident of
indecent exposure mirage was convicted
in 2003 for looking through the window
of an elderly woman's home in california
while masturbating
um he says quote i may have been
somewhere i didn't belong but i wasn't
doing it for sexual gratification and i
wasn't showing myself off mirage or
contest
roger says it was a mistake to plead
guilty when asked if he if he was there
and masturbated on the property and
roger said i don't remember that night
so i can't comment it was a long time
ago
oh yes he doesn't remember doesn't
remember if he masturbated in front of
an elderly woman's window or not
oh maybe i did maybe i can't remember so
long ago
now it may sound difficult to believe
that a person wouldn't remember whether
or not they did that but considering how
often this guy allegedly exposes himself
to women there may be some truth to it
he's just having trouble keeping it all
straight
more from the post it says mirage has
also been implicated in sex crime
investigations that do not result in
charges in june 2018 while on parole for
a burglary conviction mirager was
identified as a suspect in an alleged
indecent exposure incident at a gasoline
station
according to police report three
customers reported to the cashier that a
person with no underwear wearing a
see-through fishnet style outfit was
exposing themselves at a pump
then on december 26 2018 police
responded to the palm springs swim
center after the coaches of a high
school girls water polo team called
police according to the incident report
one of the coaches said he aggressively
confronted mirager after the schoolgirls
alerted him
that mirager had exposed his penis in
the women's changing room
and by the way as i was reading that
from the new york post i kept using
uh his and him
but the new york post was using there
because you know
it's important when we're talking about
a sex offender who is exposing himself
to to young girls it's important to
respect his pronouns still
so to review
a 52 year old male sex predator with a
long history of harassing women
including the elderly and children
entered a female locker room
exposed his erect penis to a group of
women and a child
the victims then complained to the staff
who all took the sex offender's side
and the media took the sex offender's
side
the left took the sex offender's side
what's more they said that if a male sex
pest shows his erection to you in the
locker room
it is your responsibility as a woman
to accept him as a woman
a woman with an erection to be specific
this is the actual position
of the corporate press
and the entire american left wing
if a sex offender is harassing or
assaulting you
you have to put up with it if he says
he's trans
take it one step further
a male sex offender has the right to
harass you
and expose himself to you if he says
he's trans
being transgender grants him the right
to commit sex offenses that is the
official position of the media and the
left and all these people
for the left especially those in the
media what we what we know and what we
learned from this is that their fidelity
to their religion and to the lgbt agenda
comes before everything else
before the facts before truth
before the privacy and safety of women
and girls before basic human decency
before morality before everything
now we know that
and we're accustomed to it by now we're
kind of numb to it
but that shouldn't prevent us from
realizing
and appreciating just how outrageous and
repugnant
all of this really is
now let's get to our five headlines
well you've all heard me talk plenty
about my pillow which uh you know it's a
uniquely comfortable product that you
just have to try to really experience
and once you have tried my pillow you're
not going to want to ever use another
pillow again i can tell you that
well my pillow has done it again by
introducing their new my slippers my my
pillow has taken over two years to
develop their my slippers designed to
wear indoors and outdoors all day long
made with my pillow foam and impact gel
to help prevent fatigue and they're also
made with quality leather suede and it's
yet again same situation once you try
these slippers and i'm a big slipper fan
myself
um as any middle-aged dad
should be i believe uh once you try
these slippers not gonna try any others
ever again for a limited time my
pillow's offering 50 off his new my
slippers my slippers are so comfortable
that you'll want to get some for the
whole family go to mypillow.com and
click on the radio listener square and
use promo code dailywire at checkout or
call
800-651-1148 you'll also get deep
discounts on all my pillow products
including the giza dream bed sheets the
my pillow mattress topper and the my
pillow towel sets that's mypillow.com
and enter dailywire or call
1-800-651-1148 and tell them i sent you
that's 1-800-651-1148
by the way i know i'm uh like like maybe
a year behind the times but i wanted to
mention i i finally saw the movie
tennant uh with christopher nolan
over the weekend you have to understand
uh it's a it's a high pressure situation
for me
when i'm sitting down with my
wife to watch a movie because to
convince her to watch a movie is already
you know there's there's a lot of
convincing that goes into it because
she's she's one of those these people
very common these days don't want to
watch a movie
uh i would rather watch you know i'll
sit down and watch a tv show for 30
minutes but not a movie and i can kind
of understand it because it's a big time
investment but
and so many movies are terrible but the
problem is that if if i convince her to
watch the movie now
now it's as if it's my it's it's as if
the movie is mine like i made it i'm
responsible now if it's not good
so i feel a lot of pressure
and so i said let's sit down and watch
this movie you know christopher nolan
how bad can it be
and i gotta say if you haven't seen this
film it is
terrible i mean it is awful and i know i
know you're thinking well matt you hate
everything that's not true first of all
i don't hate there are some things i
like i like fishing i like
the color blue
i like books about arctic explorers i
like two or three other things so there
are things that i like but this is just
really bad christopher nolan has has
always had this idea with his movies
that for for some reason you know you
shouldn't be allowed to understand the
dialogue in the film he thinks that the
dialogue should be a mystery
so all his characters are always
speaking in these muffled voices it
sounds like they have blankets over
their heads or like listening to the
movie it's like listening to someone
it's like trying to have a conversation
with someone two rows up from you on a
plane during takeoff
and um
and i guess in this movie what he said
is well
i already make the dialogue
unintelligible so let's make a movie
where the entire plot
and the character's motivations and
everything about it is completely
incoherent and nothing that is happening
this movie makes any sense whatsoever
it's one of those movies i think that is
it's imp it impresses a very specific iq
demographic so if you're sitting at like
a 95 a 90 to 95
not incredibly stupid but also not smart
then you'll watch this movie and you'll
think that it that it well it must be a
smart movie and so it must make sense
and so you're going to be kind of like a
person looking at the clouds trying to
discern shapes in the clouds
but if you're a little bit smarter you
watch it you go oh no this is all just
total nonsense
so really bad but still
better than any marvel movie
i'll give it that
all right so there was uh supposed to
allegedly be a right-wing rally in dc uh
to commemorate january 6th or something
or another on saturday
you know the thing is that nobody had
heard about this rally
i'm a right-winger
and um
i have my ear to the pavement i i kind
of hear about these you know if there's
going to be a big conservative
right-wing
protest somewhere you'd think i'd be the
kind of person that might hear about it
um you think you would hear about it but
but no one had heard about it
nobody knew it was supposed to happen
only the media knew about it
so the media showed up on saturday in dc
and the police showed up
and lots of feds showed up we can assume
and really nobody else here's the
reuters report about
this so-called protest let's watch
police vastly outnumbered protesters
around the u.s capitol on saturday at a
sparsely attended rally by supporters of
people who breached the building on
january 6th trying to overturn former
president donald trump's election defeat
about one to 200 protesters showed up
for the justice for j-6 rally far fewer
than the 700 organizers had expected and
the thousands who brought mayhem to the
capital on january 6th
as part of an effort by some of trump's
far-right supporters to rewrite the
history of january's deadly mob assault
speaker after speaker on saturday
insisted that hundreds of rioters
arrested that day were quote political
prisoners
okay a couple things here um
and you see a few so there were a few
there were like
you know 10 or 12
maybe actual protesters
there were about there were about 15
reporters for every actual protester
but even of the 10 or 12 we can assume
that at least half of them were in the
fbi so
how many real protesters who knows
as far as them as the the
capital rioters in prison right now
being political prisoners
they are political prisoners
in the sense that the severity of the
charges
you know the extent
to which they've been hunted down
the way they're being dealt with
all of this is politically motivated so
that's what we mean when we say
political prisoners in this
case and we know that it's politically
motivated
um we 100 percent know that
based on the comparison to the blm riots
we have this really handy comparison
that we can draw
of
violent rioting
in many cases much more violent than
what we saw
on january 6 all across the country and
we can see
how those rioters have been dealt with
and how that's been handled and we can
compare it and we can we can see okay
well
the ones at the capitol
are being dealt with in in a much much
harsher way
than blm
and we can't say that oh it's because
they attacked a government building
as we've reviewed many times blm did the
same thing they they had a blm and
antifa they had a federal courthouse
under siege for weeks
they invaded a police station burned it
down that's a government building
you would think that's a pretty
significant
crime you would think
in spite of that
we know that most of the the effort um
has been to track down january 6th and
not the blm riders and why is that well
because it's politics so political
prisoners yes in that sense
um
also in in terms of anticipating a big
turnout nobody did
no one anticipated that but the media
and it wasn't so much them anticipating
a big turnout it's that they they were
hoping for one they're begging
for another january 6th
but much worse
you know we know that after january 6
they said it was a deadly riot and they
were trying to imply that the rioters
uh you know killed several people and in
fact the writers didn't kill anybody
what they want you know they want
a real riot
that's actually as bad and violent as
they've made this one out to be that's
what they are begging for
and they couldn't get it in this case so
my condolence my condolences to the
media you didn't get uh i know what you
were looking for you were hoping some
people would die and
it would be a big mess
and it would give you something to talk
about
they would give you something you could
hang around the necks of your political
enemies and uh my condolences that you
didn't get that really really tough
really tough break i'm sorry guys
maybe next time
all right next from the daily wire it
says san francisco mayor london breed a
democrat was photographed at a jazz club
earlier this week indoors and without a
mask despite a city-wide mandate
let's play the video of her here
as i read this report from the daily
watch
you can see her there she's there's not
a mask in sight
and they are indoors and they're packed
in tight
and there's someone singing there
exhaling vigorously
spraying his aerosol particles all over
this crowd of massless people this is a
really dangerous thing going on
and this was last week
when asked on friday about her defiance
of the mass mandate breed responded with
excuses that wouldn't fly for anyone
else including a denunciation of the fun
police we have her excuses
um yeah the next day she was uh talking
to the media
and
in fact her entire she goes on for like
five or six minutes defending herself
and i'm not gonna play the entire thing
but here's a minute and a half
of her offering excuses
for defying her own mask mandate
and uh you just have to listen to this
let's listen i had a good time at the
black cat
and i think it's sad that this is even a
story
the fact is
there was something that was really
monumental that occurred
and that is tony tony tony
the original members the brothers
rafael sadiq
and dwayne wiggins
who have not performed in public for i
believe at least over 20 years
they are just really
um some of the most incredible artists
in the history of this country and the
bay area in particular
and the fact that that is getting lost
here is very unfortunate not to mention
the incredible trumpeteer
maurice mobetta brown
who
is just phenomenal these incredible
musicians who performed and who really
uplifted the spirits of not just myself
but all the people who were there
and from my perspective
you know i was there
i was eating and i was drinking and i
was sitting with my friends and everyone
who came in there was vaccinated so the
fact that we have turned this into a
story about being massless no i'm not
gonna sip and put my mask on sit and put
my mask on sip and put my mask on eat
and put my mask on
while i'm eating and i'm drinking i'm
gonna keep my mask off
okay well she was having a good time and
besides
dwayne wiggins
almost there
come on dwayne wiggins was there and
there was and there were incredible
trumpeters
i mean
look
is that not enough for you people
yes we're saying that it's a deadly
pandemic and you know if you walk
outside without a mask on you might die
and
yeah your kids have to go to school
every day in a mask
right but but dwayne wiggins was at the
club
and she was having a good time
she later on she talks about i don't
know if she said it there or not because
i was only barely paying attention but
she's she accuses the the people who are
telling her that she should obey her own
rules she's calling them the fun police
and she says that she was getting in the
spirit you know
she was just vibing to the jazz music
man chill out all right
and what is she gonna do
take you know take pull the mask down
take a sip of the drink pull the mask
back up pull it down take a sip who
would do that that's crazy i mean that's
insane it's crazy to expect anyone to do
that
i mean that's exactly what they tell you
to do on planes though
it's they tell you that explicitly they
say pull your mask down take a sip and
pull it back up those are the that's
verbatim instructions from flight
attendants on planes now she's not on a
plane granted but has has mayor london
breed come out
and uh
said how she feels about these kinds of
regulations on planes
she is apparently against the federal
guidelines on planes
she should be against them
but maybe she should say that out loud
well she only says it out loud in
defense of herself not in defense of
anybody else
now of course as always with these uh
with these coveted hypocrites
the things they're saying
in defense of their behavior
if you're to
consider that in a vacuum
it makes sense
i don't have a problem
i'm not the one with a problem if
someone
has a problem with someone going to
a nightclub and having a drink with
their friends and hanging out without a
mask on
all of that makes perfect sense
the problem of course is that those
excuses
would not fly for anybody else in san
francisco
no one else is allowed to do that
no business
is allowed to say in san francisco i'm
not going to abide by the mandates
because i just want my customers to have
a good time
they should be allowed to say that but
they can't
only mayor london breed can say that
because all animals are equal but some
are more equal than others to quote
animal farm
um animal farm which by the way i i
think if we're looking for an orwell
comparison and everyone goes to 1984 and
there's a lot there's you know certainly
a lot that's analogous there many
comparisons but i think animal farm more
and more
is the better comparison
um but she doesn't apologize
that's the other thing we always see
with democrats in general never
apologize just double down
maybe a lesson there for the rest of us
more hypocrisy um on kovid the emmys
were last night and we're just going
through all of the you know awards
ceremonies and galas and the vmas
last week no one no one cares about any
of this nobody watches any of it anymore
but they're still gonna you know they're
still gonna throw these really even they
don't have the ratings anymore to
justify it but they're still going to
throw these parties for themselves
because it makes them feel important and
that's what it's really all about but
they were indoors
maskless
at the emmys
and then seth rogen gets up there and he
calls them out for this he's getting a
lot of credit for this on online you
know the social media is impressed with
seth rogen for his courage and standing
up there and calling out his fellow
celebrities for their covet hypocrisy
but i'm not quite i'm not
quite as impressed as everybody else
seems to be let's listen to seth rogen
first
um anyway good to be here at the emmy
awards let me start by saying there is
way too many of us in this little room
what are we doing
they said this was outdoors
it's not
they lied to us
we're in a hermetically sealed tent
right now
i would not have come to this
why is there a roof
it's more important that we have three
chandeliers than that we make sure we
don't kill eugene levy tonight
yeah they're
that's perfect because they're laughing
about their hypocrisy
there's no courage in that for seth
rogen he's
just he said yeah we're hypocrites isn't
that hilarious and everyone's laughing
hysterically at it
he said i wouldn't have come to this if
i had known
really when you're like walking down the
red carpet and you've got your fancy
orange suit on you you didn't notice the
building you you could walk in you could
leave any time
do they have you at gunpoint on stage
i wouldn't be here right now if i knew
it was going to be like this and then he
stays there for another four and a half
hours
yeah that's what we have to understand
they
think
that their hypocrisy is funny it's just
a joke
this is
there's nothing remarkable about that
except that they're doing it on tv
with the cameras rolling laughing about
their own on hypocrisy
but they don't
care here's what we have to understand
about the the elites they they just
don't care
if you're upset about it
mayor london breed
i hate to even call her an elite as the
mayor of
that
garbage craphole san francisco but
you know
in a sense of being uh in charge of the
city she is so they don't care
if you're upset about it they don't care
if i'm upset about it
because to them we are
sub-human we don't our our opinions
don't matter at all
and all of these rules are for us
because we can't be trusted see mayor
breed
she can make judgment calls
and she knows that she's vaccinated and
she knows that this is a reasonable
thing to do and it's not a great risk
and everything else and she just wants
to have a go go and have a good time
that's discernment that's a judgment
call she can do that she can make that
judgment call she trusts herself
she trusts her friends to do that
but she doesn't trust you because you're
nothing but a peon
you're barely human to her
that's the way they view it
um speaking of uh here's actual
subhuman behavior this viral video that
will really make your blood boil if we
we played the video last week of the kid
on the plane being forced to wear a mask
and
you might have thought it can't get any
worse than that but it can uh here's a
very young child at a daycare center and
when i say very young i mean this kid
looks to be under two maybe 18 months 18
to 20 months or somewhere in that that
range
and he is screaming while the harpies at
the daycare center try to put the muzzle
on him let's watch some of this video
[Music]
there you go keep it right there yay
yay
[Music]
you feeling me
look we're gonna keep it right here
[Music]
put your mask back on
[Music]
[Music]
that's just ungodly rage it fills me
with watching that
as a parent i don't even like the it
gives me heart palpitations just to see
a kid that age with anything around his
neck
okay
and if you have any experience with
young kids you know that's that's
not paranoia i mean
if it's paranoia it's less paranoid to
be worried about that than it is to be
worried about covet for a kid that age
i would be more worried about him having
that thing around his neck and getting
tangled and somehow he ends up choking
himself
um i mean one of the with with with kids
that age one of the most dangerous
things in your home
is that like the the cord on your blinds
kids get their necks wrapped around that
and uh essentially hang themselves these
kind of things these kinds of things
happen
so that alone is a reason why i wouldn't
put that mask on a kid
and there are about 100 other reasons on
top of it
now child
as i said i i think under two years old
we don't know the exact age
he doesn't have
full words yet you can tell
which means he can't he can't also you
also can't understand everything that's
being told to him
so there's no way to communicate to a
child that age
why he needs to wear a mask
which means that kids that age they're
either not going to wear the mask that's
a that that is a normal healthy child
reaction to putting something on their
face like that
have you ever tried putting like a hat
on a kid
forget about something on their face try
putting some a hat on their head
or it's raining out and you know they've
got their little rain jacket on you try
to put the hood up so they don't get
their their hair wet
how long does that thing stay on there
10 seconds
now how in the world would you keep
something on their face if you can't
even keep something on their head
and the answer is in in most cases with
healthy kids
and by that i mean psychologically
healthy kids you're not going to be able
to do it they just will not go along
with it
they're not capable of going along with
something like that
and yet you hear from parents
who say in in by way of defending
masking kids
they say oh my kid i have a two-year-old
and he wears the mask
without a problem whenever we go out i
send him to daycare i send him a
preschool
we go to target and he wears the mask
the whole time
now i think a lot of these parents are
probably lying
but not all of them
now i have seen kids that look as as
young as that or younger walking around
you know places
with uh with masks on their face and not
really fidgeting much with it
and so you just have to think
what did those parents
and the adults in that child's life
what did they have to do to that child
to make him cooperate with this
it is it's
bone chilling to think about
the psychological abuse
the amount of fear that they would have
to instill in a child to get a child
that age to cooperate with something
like that
you would have to absolutely scare them
senseless
repeatedly
you would have to drill this fear into
their
little heads
and it would have to be a
a terror campaign that you're waging
against your child
um consistently
until it really sinks in
that's the only way a kid that age will
go along with it
is if they are terrified
that if they don't take the mask off
they'll die
and you gotta really try to get that
message into their heads
and then once you've done that
and there's no psychologi there's no
recovering from that psychologically
you have really and truly emotionally
and psychologically scarred your kid
permanently
you've caused developmental mental
developmental uh
psychological developmental
issues that aren't going to magically go
away
of all the things we worry about we hear
we hear about people being emotionally
traumatized and psychologically
traumatized and we hear about our kids
are going to be traumatized if they you
know if they get a failing grade on a
report card and so we gotta get rid of
the grading system and all this kind of
stuff
all the worrying we do over trauma and
the way that the word trauma is so
abused and misapplied and yet here is an
actual example of it that is real trauma
that you are inflicting on a child
and of course we know that the exact
same people
there's a there is an almost 100 overlap
between the people who think that a you
know a failing grade will traumatize a
child so we got to get rid of the
grading system and the people who think
that it's not traumatizing at all
to force a very young child to wear a
face mask and to tell him that if he
takes it off he might die
all right finally uh doug gottlieb is
the former fda commissioner and he has
some information on the origins
of the six feet social distancing
guideline uh or
rather his information is that there's
no information on the origins because
nobody knows the origins but let's
listen to him
and you write the six feet was arbitrage
the six feet was arbitrary in and of
itself but if the administration had
focused in on that
they might have been able to affect a
policy that would have actually achieved
their outcome but
that policy making process didn't exist
and the six feet is a perfect example of
sort of the
lack of
rigor around how cdc made
recommendations nobody knows where it
came from most people assume that the
six feet of distance the recommendation
for keeping six feet apart comes out of
some old studies related to flu where
droplets don't travel more than six feet
we now know covet spreads through
aerosols we've known that for a while so
how operative is that the initial
recommendation that the cdc brought to
the white house and i talked about this
was 10 feet and a political appointee in
the white house said we can't recommend
10 feet nobody can measure 10 feet it's
inoperable society will shut down so the
compromise was around six feet
that's that's bureaucracy for you i can
think of no if you want to understand
what bureaucracy is
if you want to understand the problem
with uh
bureaucracy and being governed by a
bureaucratic state
watch that video
that's it right there in less than 60
seconds
here's this is a policy that was put in
place
and that we have been forced to reorient
our lives around this policy
businesses have been shut down across
the country permanently because of this
policy of social distancing not all
businesses could enforce it
or could operate around it
and so here's a policy that has had
enormous impact
on everybody's life
devastating impact
put in place by the government and
nobody knows who came up with it or why
that's how bureaucracies work they're
designed this way they are designed to
bureaucracies are groups of people
but the idea is that the groups of
people can do things
but no no individual in that group will
be responsible for those things having
been done
which means that nobody is ever held
accountable
because there's nobody to hold account
to hold to account
there's not like one guy you can look to
and say well he's the one who told us
about this
every once in a while if they really if
they're really feeling the heat they'll
offer up some kind of some poor sap some
some sacrificial lamb and they'll say oh
yeah it was all this guy's fault
we didn't know we didn't know this guy's
name until you know
until 30 minutes ago but yeah it's his
fault
so every once in a while they'll do that
but
in terms of holding the real
responsible parties to account
never happens because
as far as the bureaucracy is concerned
the bureaucracy just sort of acts
it just
does things
and it never filters down to one
individual person
of course you would think that if that's
the case at least the people running the
bureaucracies fauci for example
maybe we could hold them accountable
but we can't hold them accountable
either because they can always point
down the the food chain
and once you get down the food chain the
accountability just sort of evaporates
into thin air
so six feet of social distancing this is
based on
no science
completely arbitrary
there's no reason to have been following
it
and yet even now
you're anti-science if you question it
i could probably go on twitter right now
and say social distances six feet of
social distancing is arbitrary and
nonsensical and
not rooted in science and uh you know i
would be suspended from the platform
for misinformation
all right let's move now to reading the
youtube
comments
who's rocking polka dot and flannel
shirts without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
oh
that was sudden
can we find a happy medium it's like
that's too short before it was too long
i just don't know what i want i guess
can't make up my mind
all right uh let's see prill says talk
he's talking about the national divorce
idea that we discussed on friday says
unlike most real divorces
uh this one would be the kid's fault
entirely
well i have to disagree with you there
and so you're saying if we if the
country has to break up
the american experiment is no longer
working the the the union is is
dissolving
you're saying all that blame goes what
to the younger generations millennials
and
gen z
come on
what generation has been in control for
the last 30 years
we've been living under boomer control
for decades now
how has that worked
and you want to absolve
the generation that created this country
that we're currently living in
we're going to absolve them of all blame
almost every politician on a national
level who has helped to drive this
country into the ground over the last 30
years they haven't been millennials
certainly not gen z
no i'm not as a millennial am i saying
that we absolve our generation of blame
of course not
i'm no apologist for millennials that's
for sure
but
this thing we do where we want to you
know
we want to always point to the younger
generations it doesn't work that way
it's like you're
you're handing off a vehicle
and the vehicle is already on fire
and you're giving it to the next
generation and they take it around the
block a couple spins and they bring it
back and the fire is a like
there's a little bit more smoke
billowing out of the engine and you go
what'd you do with my car what happened
to my car
the car was was the car might be in a
little bit worse shape now but it was
totaled
before they even got in it so
slow your roll there a little bit all
right bernard says matt's matt walsh's
daughter's method of persuasion sounds
an awful lot like a theocratic dictator
she's a chip off the old block she is
and i couldn't be prouder daniel says i
love matt's stories about his kids
reminds me that my kids aren't uniquely
insane
uh yeah i mean kids are all weird man
they're very weird you you realize that
one of the main things you realize early
on as a parent
kids are strange
and you always think i don't remember
being this strange when i was a kid but
i guess i was
i was thinking about this yesterday when
i was reading to my youngest son
four years old
uh before
nap time he still has a nap time and
we're clinging on to his nap time uh
as much as we possibly can but i was
reading hansel and gretel to my youngest
son he's going through a phase right now
where he really loves that story the
hansel and gretel story he's like
obsessed with it he wants to he wants it
to be read to him every day multiple
times a day sometimes
um
and you know i'm sitting down and i'm
reading this story to him thinking
this story is horrifying
it's been a while since i've read it
you know it's like
hansel and gretel they're these
neglected kids
the the stepmother
they're at home with their dad and
stepmother stepmother's evil stepmother
and she convinces the dad to abandon the
kids he doesn't want to but he but he's
this hen-pecked husband she says oh we
should abandon the kids in the middle of
the forest because we don't have enough
food to split with them and so he says i
don't want to do it but i will and he
abandons the kid and then they're
wandering in the forest and they end up
at this this uh house that's made of the
gingerbread and they go in and there's
this old lady who looks really kind but
then she tries to eat them
and then they escape and that's the end
of the story
and i'm reading it and i'm thinking not
that i'm blaming my kid for the fact
that this story is so weird but what do
you like about this story
you weirdo
i didn't say that but i thought it
um stan says matt i tend to find that
you're a little too apathetic on animal
rights now by no means am i some greta
thunberg simp i'm not vegan etc but i
view it like the climate i think we
should be more respectful to it on
principle
god made them he created them like he
created us yes he gave us intelligence
he gave us a real soul a real humanity
he didn't give the rest of the animals
those things but that doesn't mean we
should just treat them as useless or as
worthless
that's still a living creature a work of
god i think we should be a little bit
more respectful towards animals and the
climate for those reasons
uh i don't
disagree with that
i mean the idea of being respectful to
the climate to me is a little bit weird
respect the weather i'm not sure but i
get what you're saying in general nature
you know respect nature
um you don't want to go
you know
deforesting for no reason um
and uh you don't want to pollute and
those sorts of things you want to
respect animals
i don't believe in killing animals for
no reason if you're going to kill an
animal to eat the animal that's that's
fine so i don't i don't disagree with
you it's just that
i don't really connect with
animal rights issues on an emotional
level and i and i admit that
um
[Music]
joel ellie says while i don't agree with
lil na's x's politics at all i do agree
that he has no responsibility to cater
to children that's like forcing someone
like dave chappelle to have
child-friendly comedy just because he's
starting a kids movie before it's our
responsibility as parents to shield our
kids away from material
that's not suitable for them i do agree
that it's no one is saying that it's
primarily will not ex's responsibility
to shield your children over your own
responsibility of course it's primarily
your own as the parent
but this is a unique situation because
this is a guy who came onto the scene as
essentially a child's artist and he
intentionally cultivated that reputation
and then it wasn't a gradual change
over years where he started focusing on
more adult oriented material quote
unquote
uh this was a sudden shift
where we went from
performing at elementary schools to
twerking on satan's lap
and uh yes i i do think that he has some
responsibility
to the audience of children that he has
cultivated not that he cares in the
slightest and finally peter says matt
how will you celebrate episode 800 i
think you should raise the price of your
spg merch to 200 and command your sweet
babies to buy it
um that's not a bad idea and that's
right this is the 800th episode which is
a huge milestone we've done 800 of these
damn things
and in all seriousness you know
i do want to take a rare moment to
be totally sincere and say that it's
been such a rewarding journey for these
past
800 shows um and i believe that we're
truly building
something special and uh we couldn't do
it without any of you and most
especially it brings
my heart great joy to know
that together we're forming this
community of like-minded people
who can all come together in the belief
that all pandas must die
because that i think is the most
important thing we've established over
these last 800 episodes well it may not
always feel like it when you're online
because you might feel secure you're
just sitting there on your phone or on
your laptop or whatever but the fact is
every time you go online you are putting
your information at risk and there are a
lot of bad actors out there who are
going to be ready to take advantage of
that payment apps like venmo cash app
and others make payments easy but you
may want to adjust your privacy settings
to prevent them from sharing your
personal information a recent report
found that payment apps share user data
with third parties such as banks fraud
monitoring services and some even share
it with marketing firms it's important
to understand how cyber crime and
identity theft are affecting our lives
every day and they are affecting our
lives every day every day we put our
information at risk on the internet in
an instant a cyber criminal could harm
what's yours your finances your credit
your reputation i mean your whole life
could be ruined by this stuff that's why
it's so good that there is lifelock life
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats especially the threats
that you might not know about if you're
just you know monitoring your own credit
or looking at your bank account and all
that kind of stuff you also have access
to a dedicated restoration specialist if
you do become a victim so nobody can
prevent all identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses but
you can keep what's yours with lifelock
by norton join now and save up to 25
percent off your first year at
lifelock.com welsh that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off
and you know the buying administration
has declared war on all businesses with
over 100 employees in the form of
mandatory vaccinations or mandatory
weekly testing
and the daily wire is not standing for
it why well because the daily wire has
over 100 employees and they refuse to
subject us to this violation of our
personal medical freedom companies like
ours that refuse to comply could face up
to fourteen thousand dollars for each
violation which could get pretty
crippling pretty fast and i can't think
of a better reason to let the fines pile
up then for opposing medical tyranny and
the erasure of freedom so we need your
help in this fight go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code do not comply at
checkout for 25 off americans have been
far too willing to cede their freedoms
to authoritarian bureaucrats in the name
of public health for far too long enough
is enough so stand with us go to
dailywire.com subscribe and use code do
not comply now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
the buy administration has in less than
a year claimed unprecedented power for
itself it'd probably not be an
exaggeration to say that biden is the
most powerful president in american
history he's also about as cognizant as
a cantaloupe at this point perhaps it
would be more accurate to say that he's
the most powerful cantaloupe in american
history or most accurately of all his
administration his handlers the people
running the show are the ones with the
power and they're not satisfied
because power mad tyrants are never
satisfied they want more power more
authority more control over your life
which is why president cantaloupe and
his administration are now pushing
congress to grant the irs access to your
bank account
and i mean almost everyone's bank
accounts
here's the wall street journal reporting
treasuries treasury secretary janet
yellen and irs commissioner charles
reddig pressed lawmakers wednesday to
give the internal revenue service more
information about taxpayers bank
accounts as the buy administration tries
to salvage its struggling tax compliance
proposal
in letters to lawmakers the
administration officials again asked
congress to require banks to report
annual inflows and outflows from bank
accounts with at least 600 or at least
600 worth of transactions
a proposal aimed at letting the irs
target its audits more effectively it
would generate about 460 billion dollars
over the course
of a decade to cover the cost of
democrats planned expansion of the um
social safety net and climate change
policies according to the administration
so
if you're
one of those wealthy fat cats with more
than 600 in your account
then the irs wants to know about all of
your inflows and outflows
okay no big deal there really nothing
major they just want to know your entire
transaction history
they want to know about
every
dime you receive and spend
that's all
now um
there are some who have raised
objections to this plan if you can
imagine
they seem to care about silly things
like privacy and fundamental human
liberty and other super superfluous
concerns the irs has a response to all
of that from the wall street journal
again
it says quote treasury officials have
been trying to respond to those concerns
pointing to research showing that tax
compliance is higher when when when
people know that the irs has independent
sources of information about their
finances such as w-2 wage reporting
a reporting regime that is broad-based
will better assist the irs in targeting
enforcement priorities on the high end
who accrue income in opaque ways ms
yellen wrote wednesday in one of the
several letters from the treasury
officials to ways and means committee
chairman richard neal quote any
suggestion that instead this reporting
regime will be used to target
enforcement efforts or of ordinary
americans is wholly misguided
financial institutions currently must
report
interest dividend and investment income
to the irs the irs can also get bank
account information during audits
uh miss yellen contended that compliant
taxpayers would actually benefit because
they would have a lower risk of a
burdensome audit
she wrote that compliance costs wouldn't
be high because the irs and banks would
just expand a current reporting
structure for interest income
ah well there you go
they need access to all of your accounts
and your entire transaction history
because it will help you be more
obedient
and the good news is that if you are
obedient then you have nothing to worry
about in fact if the irs is allowed to
have access to your accounts then maybe
they won't need to audit you
if they don't have access then you know
they're going to have to audit you
of course the reason they won't audit
you if they have access to your accounts
is because they're already auditing you
what is being proposed here is a
permanent audit of nearly every tax
paying american forever
over a decade we're told that this will
generate 460 billion dollars in
additional revenue
because they'll be catching all of those
dastardly cheaters and everything uh 460
billion dollars in deck in a decade is
what they're talking about
which the which the government will then
spend in one month
so that's the deal
you forfeit all of your financial
privacy all of it
and go under a permanent irs audit and
in exchange the government over the
course of 10 years will raise enough
additional money to run its operations
for four weeks
who could possibly object
well i'll tell you who is not objecting
the conservatives over at the bulwark
conservatives quote unquote the bulwark
uh founded by never trump conservatives
and so named because it's supposed to be
a bulwark a last defense heroically
preserving conservatism
published a piece on friday by
conservative quote-unquote jim swift
defending this irs proposal and accusing
all who oppose it of being in league
with tax evaders
swift writes quote
what the democrats want to do is give
the irs more knowledge about where and
how money flows as the irs commissioner
wrote last month more and better data
will provide the irs with a lens into
otherwise opaque sources of income with
historically lower levels of reporting
accuracy
in opposing this measure republicans
claim they're standing up for privacy
and for people who don't yet have bank
accounts but hypothetically might
someday
but they are really covering for tax
cheats bottom line while giving the irs
the ability to catch tax cheats with
accounts with balances over 600 make a
dent in the tax cap yes
will it impinge on your freedom
not significantly no
oh okay so you see there the democrats
simply want complete and permanent
access to your financial information
because it will help close the tax gap
will it take away your freedom not
significantly no
then again you know biden could put us
all in chains and lock us in the white
house dungeon
and jim swift would still be there
chained to the wall with a rat nibbling
at his toes and scolding the rest of us
for complaining about it
this is for your own good listen to me
i'm the real conservative here
now obviously if concepts like financial
freedom and privacy mean anything
i mean if they have any value any
meaning then we can't submit to a plan
like this
you could only support this plan if you
fundamentally oppose the idea that we
the citizens should be able to keep
anything private from our government
overlords at all
what about the tax cap what about
catching tax cheaters
well the irs will have to use the
already considerable tools at its
disposable at its disposal to do that
though i have to confess personally you
know i don't really care if people are
cheating
i'll tell you that right now
the idea that tax cheaters are
measurably harming the country by
depriving the government of their income
is absurd when you consider the fact
that the government already collects 3.5
trillion dollars a year in taxes if it
can't figure out how to keep itself
operational with 3.5 trillion dollars a
year
and it can't because it spends almost
double what it takes in
then the problem cannot be solved by
giving it more
you know this is a fact of life that
holds true at every level
if you're not responsible with a little
bit of money
you're not going to suddenly be
responsible when you have more money
this is one of the reasons why people
who win the lottery always the lottery
almost always ruins their life because
if you're playing the lottery
it probably means that you're not
responsible with your money
and if you're not responsible with a
little bit of money you have and now you
have 50 million dollars or 500 million
dollars
it's going to ruin your life
and for the government if you aren't
responsible with 3.5 trillion dollars
then you're not going to be responsible
with an additional half trillion over a
decade
it's a very sad thing that these
slobbering wasteful drunks can bilk
nearly four trillion dollars in taxes
every year
and still cry that it's not enough
and even so-called conservatives will
take the sob story seriously
oh no they can't make do on 3.5 trillion
we have to give up all of our financial
independence and privacy forever to
solve this problem is what they tell us
but none of this is is too surprising um
it was always inevitable that it would
get to this point once the government
claimed the authority to tax us simply
for earning an income
and then even granted itself the power
to take its portion of our income from
our checks automatically without us even
having to send the money in
so the path has been paved for quite
some time
and now some conservatives
especially those over at the bulwark
are happy to walk down it
and for that reason
they are the ones who are canceled today
and we'll leave it there
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there